The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
talk about routing protocols.
And today we're going to talk
about how routing protocols
handle failures.
So I'm going to--
I want to bring everybody back
onto the same page with respect
to where we are in the story.
So in terms of
routing protocols,
if you imagine a network
topology like this, and let's
say that links have costs
associated with them.
So I'm just going to make
up some numbers here.
We studied two classes
of routing protocols.
And we looked at these in
the absence of any failures.
The first is the distance vector
protocol, or more generally,
vector protocols where,
in an advertisement sent
from one node to
another, each node sends
a subset of its routing table.
In other words, it sends two
columns from its routing table.
Recall that the routing
table at every node
contains a destination,
a route, which
is a link, the name of
the link, and a cost.
And in a distance
vector protocol,
you send these two columns.
You send these tuples for all of
the destinations that you know.
And that's what's spread out
to all of the other nodes.
In contrast-- so this
is distance vector.
In contrast, in a
link state protocol,
what you're sending to
all of the other nodes
is information about all
of the links that you have.
And in particular,
you send information
about the neighbor
in your topology
together with the link
cost to that neighbor,
whereas here it's the cost of
the route to the destination
that you send.
In the distance vector protocol,
the computation of the routes
is distributed.
So every node kind of
computes and updates
its routing table using the
Bellman-Ford update step, which
essentially updates the
route to a destination
if you find a better
route to the destination.
Or if you find that the route
to the destination has--
that you currently have
"has a changed cost,"
in which case, you update
your routing table.
In a link state protocol, the
computation is not distributed.
What is distributed
is the process
of flooding this information
of the local links.
That's why it's called
a link state protocol.
And the computation of
the routes themselves
are centralized.
Each node just runs a
shortest path computation--
for example, Dijkstra's
shortest path computation.
And in a link state protocol,
as long as all of the nodes run
exactly the same
computation-- in other words,
they all try to minimize or
optimize the same metric--
then you're guaranteed
that all of the nodes
end up computing
the correct routes,
and that when you send
a packet from one node,
it will reach the
destination, assuming
there's a path in the network.
And in the problem set--
maybe not in the problems.
Certainly at the
back of the chapter,
there are problems
on what happens
if some nodes run one
protocol and another node
runs another protocol.
For example, you might have--
imagine a routing protocol
where one of the nodes is doing
minimum cost routes and another
node is doing shortest paths--
in terms of the number
of hops, not costs.
And if you have that, you
might end up in a situation
where, in fact, the routing
doesn't work correctly.
But assuming that
all of the nodes
are on the same optimization
in a link state protocol,
they'll all get
the correct answer.
And similarly, in a
distance vector protocol,
actually the update
rule can do anything,
as long as the nodes
believe that this route--
and they perform some sort of
an update to the routing table
entry consistent with the
information that they hear,
then the routing will work.
Now, what happens when
there are failures?
And how does it work?
So let's say that you run this
protocol and this topology.
And you give it enough time.
Once you hear all of
the advertisements
and compute the routes
of the different nodes,
if you look at this
node over here,
C four destination D
would have a route--
let's call this link L0.
It will have a route, L0.
And the cost of that
route would be three.
And similarly at B here, once
it converges you'd have--
for destination D, let's
imagine this link is called L0,
as well, at node B.
You might have L0
and the cost would be four, and
similarly at the other nodes.
Now, let's say what happens
is that some sort of a failure
occurs.
And failures could be one of--
a variety of failures could
occur that cause the routing
to get screwed up.
So one of the failures-- the
easiest form of failure--
is that a packet could be lost.
In particular, an
advertisement could be lost.
The second thing
that could happen
is that a link could fail.
I mean, if it's a
wire, maybe a backhoe
runs over it, which is actually
more common than you think.
In fact, you could
have undersea cables
where sharks bite them
and they get destroyed.
I mean, lots of
things could happen.
So links could fail.
And the third thing
that could happen,
which is more common
than you might think,
is that entire switches could
fail or nodes could fail.
Since we actually don't know
how to write bug-free software,
software bugs may
cause things to fail.
They may cause things to crash.
In fact, they may cause things
to fail in mysterious ways
where it looks like
it's not failed,
but in fact, there's a fault
in the software causing
you to send bad advertisements.
And for this course, we
won't worry about this.
We'll actually worry about
only a class of failures
that we think of as fail stop.
What I mean by that
is if it fails,
it just stops, as opposed to
it fails and then it gives you
wrong information, which is
actually a lot harder to deal
with, because it's
much better for you
to fail and just stop
rather than for the node
to fail and pretend that
it's correct and send you
bad information.
That's a lot harder
to deal with.
We'll worry about that
later, not in 6.02.
Anyway, these
things could happen.
So let's concretely assume that
you have this topology here.
And what happens
is this link fails.
Now, if you did nothing
and you had that link fail,
what would happen?
Now, let's look at
it node by node.
What would happen here
is that C would end up
with no route to the
destination, because what
would happen is assuming that
C has some way of discovering
that this fault has
happened, it would have
no route to the destination.
But if it doesn't discover
the fault had happened,
it has this route
to the destination.
But if it sends
packets on that link,
it wouldn't reach
the other side.
Packets would be lost.
But assuming that
it discovers, has
a way of discovering that
this link has failed,
it has no route to
the destination.
Now, B has a route
to the destination.
It has this link.
But in fact, the next
advertisement from C,
if C were to make
another advertisement,
would tell it that it had
no route to the destination.
But if it did nothing, if you
did nothing in the protocol,
B thinks it has a route
to the destination.
But in fact, it reaches C
and it's actually a dead end
because it reaches
C and C doesn't
know what to do with it.
It just drops the packet.
The technical term for
this is a dead end.
You send packets.
You think you're
reaching the destination.
But it's actually
getting dropped.
What about S?
Does S have a route
to the destination?
Well, S doesn't have a route
to the destination, either,
because the right route
to the destination
would probably have
been this link over here
because the cost
was 2 plus 1 plus 3.
And that wouldn't have a
route to the destination.
It would have a
route, but the route
would lead to a dead
end at C. And in fact,
in this particular
example, no node
would have a route to
the destination in terms
of the routing table itself.
No node would have a route
that actually worked,
in that the route
wouldn't correspond
to an actual working path.
But if you look at the
picture, clearly there
are other ways to get
to the destination.
I mean, we designed
this topology presumably
because we had some
sort of redundancy.
So if this failed, what
you would like to have
is for C to use one
of the other paths.
C might use this path or
C might use this path.
Or C might-- yeah, those
are the two possible paths
it could use.
And similarly, S might use--
should use that
path, and so forth.
So what you want is
a routing protocol
that converges to the
new correct answer,
assuming there is a
new correct answer.
And if there's no
new correct answer,
it converges to whatever
the best possible answer is.
So to some destinations,
you could have a route,
and to some destinations,
you don't have a route.
So what you want is, as long
as there is a connected path,
there is a path between a
source and a destination,
you would like that
source to end up
with a route that corresponds
to some good working path,
and in particular,
converges to the new minimum
cost working path between the
source and the destination.
So that's the statement
of the problem.
And we're going to solve that
problem today for both distance
vector and link scale.
And interestingly,
the idea that we're
going to use the same
idea in both cases.
And the idea is, just like
we built a redundant topology
by having alternate
paths between places,
we're just going to
repeat advertisements.
And we're going to repeat
the process of processing
these advertisements.
It's a very simple idea.
And the general plan-- there
are three steps to the plan.
The first step in the plan
is to periodically check--
every neighbor is
responsible for checking
the health of-- every node
is responsible for checking
the health of its neighbors.
So that's the step,
which we're going
to call neighbor aliveness.
And the protocol we're
going to use for that
is called the hello protocol.
It's a very, very
simple protocol.
I'll describe it in a moment.
And we're going to use this
idea that every node is
responsible for checking whether
each of its neighbors is alive.
And if it determines that
a neighbor is not alive,
it assumes the neighbor
is dead and removes
it from various tables and
data structures and so on.
And in fact, this
fail stop assumption
is pretty crucial for us,
because the assumption is
that when a failure occurs
of a node, that in fact,
the node doesn't respond.
If a failure occurs of a link,
the assumption here, as well,
is that the link
stops responding.
You don't get to send packets or
receive packets over that link.
And for now, we're going to
assume that every link is
bidirectional.
So you send packets
in both directions.
In reality, there are
unidirectional network links.
And you have to deal with
the problem differently.
Not going to worry about that.
So there is a protocol
called the hello protocol
that runs to detect if your
neighbor is alive or not.
The second step in our answer
is to make the advertisements
periodic.
And the third step
is, what do you
do when you receive
an advertisement?
When you receive
an advertisement,
you collect a bunch of
these advertisements
that you receive from
various neighbors.
In the link state protocol,
it's these link state
advertisements.
In the distance vector protocol,
it's these distance vector
tuple advertisements.
And then you run a periodic
integration process.
So if you look at
it with a timeline,
every node asynchronously--
in other words,
independent of the other nodes.
You don't have to
synchronize the clocks.
Every node has its own clock.
And every node does these
two steps periodically.
So from time to time, it
sends an advertisement.
It just says, in
distance vector,
just sends these two
columns to its neighbors.
In the link state
advertisement, it just
sends out its link
state information,
and the flooding process works.
And then from time
to time, there's
this integration of these
advertisements that happen.
Et cetera.
Now the beautiful part
of these protocols
is that I've shown
this picture here
with these integrations
happening interspersed
with the advertisements.
That doesn't actually
have to be the case.
You could do them pretty
much arbitrarily as long
as you do them periodically.
The beautiful part
of these protocols
is that every node
asynchronously running
these advertisement steps
and these integration
steps, as long as they
do this periodically,
in the end what you get
as a property called
eventual convergence.
What that means is, assuming
you have all sorts of failures
and any pattern of packet
losses, link failures,
and switches, and then
you freeze the system
and assume that no more
failures happen, then what
eventual convergence means
is that in some finite time,
all of the nodes in the
network will converge
to correct routing state.
That is, in these routing
protocols, all of the nodes
will end up with an answer
that's consistent with what
you are trying to optimize.
For example, minimum cost
paths to all the destinations.
Now, proving that under
an arbitrary model
of when these advertisements
and integration steps are all
asynchronous and being
done at random times
is a little involved.
And we're not going to
attempt that in this course.
The notes talk a
little bit about how
you get eventual
convergence when
you assume that all
the nodes are running
very periodic advertisement
steps interspersed
with integration steps.
The proof is really
not that important.
What's more important is for
you to understand the intention
behind why it works.
So I'll do that by
some examples here.
I have to also tell you
what the Hello protocol is.
I'll get to that.
But for now, just assume
it's a module that
tells you if the
neighbor is alive or not.
So is this plan
clear to everybody?
It's just this same
idea, except every node's
doing this periodically.
So in practice, you
might do this every 30
seconds or every three minutes
or something like that.
Of course, the longer the
time between advertisements,
the longer it's going
to take for the protocol
to converge after a failure
or a set of failures.
And the shorter the time, it
takes a quicker amount of time
to converge.
But you end up doing
a lot more work.
And moreover, in practice,
many failures are transient.
So a link may fail for a few
seconds and then come back up.
And so it's in practice not
that useful to converge very,
very quickly or react
very, very quickly.
It's important to
converge quickly once you
start the convergence process.
But once you-- detecting that
a neighbor is alive or dead
on the timescale
of a few packets
is sometimes too fast,
because sometimes failures
last for very little time
and then they go away.
And in the meantime, you
have done all this work
to converge to a
new routing state.
And then when the
link comes back up,
you're going to do more work
to come back to the old answer.
You may as well have
just been a little lazy.
And so deciding these
times is tricky.
And there's no real systematic
way of doing it in practice.
But the trade-off is usually
between how quickly you
wish to converge
and how much work
you're willing to expand in
making that convergence happen.
So is the plan clear?
It's just this same
protocol, except we're
going to do this periodically.
OK.
So the first step is
this enable liveness,
or the hello protocol.
So that protocol is
actually very easy.
Every node-- you have a set of
links coming out of the node
and then neighbors at
the other end of it.
So the problem is
that the node needs
to decide which of these links
is working or not working
and which of the neighbors are
still there versus not there.
And the way the
protocol works is
that every node in the
system on each of its links--
let's call these nodes ABC.
On each of these
links sends out--
periodically sends out
only to its neighbors
a packet called a Hello packet.
And the Hello packet usually
has a sequence number
on it, an incrementing
sequence number.
The idea is now
very, very simple.
This may be sent periodically,
say, every 10 seconds.
If n finds that a certain
number of hello packets--
it hasn't heard from its
neighbor, one of its neighbors,
in some time-- that is,
perhaps three hello packets are
missing, or four hello
packets are missing in a row--
it just decides that
that neighbor is dead.
It's a very simple idea.
So you send out hello
packets periodically
and if k successive
missing hello packets
implies the neighbor from
which those packets are missing
is dead.
Now, in response,
what happens is
that all of the routes
that this node had that
went via that neighbor,
via that link,
are eliminated from
the routing table.
And you could do that by
either simply removing
the entry from the routing
table or by keeping
the entry in the routing
table but making--
for those destinations--
and replacing
the cost from whatever
the value was to infinity.
And it's probably a better idea
to replace it with infinity.
I'm not exactly sure why.
That's kind of what
most people do.
I think the reason
is that you'd like
to know that that destination
exists in the network.
And then when the later route
arrives, you can fix it.
But you could just
remove it, as well.
The other thing that happens
is, if you were in a link state
protocol, what you would then
do is on the next advertisement
of the link state,
you would simply
eliminate that link and
that neighbor altogether.
So you would not advertise
this link and this neighbor
as existing anymore.
And when that link state
advertisement floods
through the network,
all of the other nodes
through the flooding
process would
determine that that
node has gone away
and that link has gone away.
And then when they run
Dijkstra's algorithm again
and recompute the routes,
they will no longer
assume that that link exists.
And they may find new
routes to the destination.
So that's what the
hello protocol does.
And so how you pick k, again,
it's the same trade-off.
It depends on how
quickly you want
to converge to a real failure.
And picking this is
difficult. For example,
if you were on a
wireless network
where the normal packet
loss probability might
be 10%, something high,
then waiting for a larger
number of successive
failed packets
is a good idea, because
just because a packet's lost
or two packets are lost doesn't
mean the link has failed.
On the other hand, if you
were running on a highly,
highly reliable link in
terms of packet loss-- like,
you were running on some
dedicated optical link where
the packet loss rate is
one part in a million--
then a single packet missing
or two packets missing
would be a good indication that
that link has actually failed
or that node at the other
end of the link has failed,
and therefore, k could be small.
So again, it totally depends
on the actual system context
and the normal
packet loss rates,
because what you're
trying to do is
to make sure you
react to real failure,
not to simply packet loss.
There's really no way
to tell the difference.
There's no way to tell the
difference between a link that
really has failed versus a link
with a high packet loss rate.
It's a heuristic.
And in fact, there's
really no way
to tell between a node that has
actually failed and gone away
and a node that's just
heavily overloaded
and is extremely
slow in responding.
There's no way to tell.
So these are all
heuristics that you
have to work with and
try to solve the problem.
So sometimes you
may get it wrong.
Sometimes you may
find that a link has--
you may declare a link to have
failed when, in fact, it's
still fine.
But that's life.
And you just have
to deal with it.
So is the story clear
so far as to how we deal
with routing and a failure?
So we're going to apply
that to this picture.
And you'll find that
the answer will work.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Like I said, what it--
let me repeat this.
What it does is, first
of all, it really
now assumes that both the
node and the link have failed.
It doesn't really know.
Now, it can definitively assume
that the link has failed.
The node may still be alive,
because it may well be
that there is a path like that.
And n wants to find that route
via A to that destination.
So what it does is
really two things.
The first thing
it does is it may
have routes in its routing
table going through that link.
This link is now
considered dead.
And therefore, it should
remove those routes.
And then in subsequent
advertisements,
it should make sure that
the cost to that destination
is infinity, which is why you
would remove it and replace
the cost to be infinity
so that you tell
the other guys that
previously I told you
I could get to B with
the cost of five,
but really now it's infinity.
The second thing that's done
in the link state protocol
is when you advertise-- you
no longer advertise that link.
So really, the answer
to your question
is it assumes that
the link has failed.
It makes no determination
about the node.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
A good protocol--
and this will be
tested in your lab
eight, in p-set eight,
is if a link fence and
eventually comes back up,
we would like for you to
actually find that answer.
And this is an
important requirement.
So if the broadcast--
that's why all the stuff
that's done in the background
is done periodically.
So if a link comes
back up, you want
to find the correct answer.
Any other questions?
OK.
So let me apply this idea
to this picture here.
So what happened here
was this thing failed.
So C is, at this point in time--
let's assume we're doing
distance vector, this protocol
here-- so C is going to assume
that this link has failed.
And therefore, it tells
all of the other guys
in its next advertisement--
it tells these other
guys that it no longer
has a route to destination
D. And it does that
by sending in its next
link state advertisement.
Previously, it would have sent--
you know what?
Did I tell everybody
that you send out
the destination and the
route in the links--
in the advertisement?
I may have done that.
I meant the destination
and the cost.
So maybe I should call this the
cost and change that to route.
So this is the stuff that's
sent in the advertisements.
And these two columns
are in the routing table.
But anyway, right
now here what would
be advertised as D
at a cost of three,
we replace that now
with D with the cost
of infinity in
our advertisements
to our neighbors.
So that's what C
would advertise.
And B, when it receives
that, would now
find that the route
that it gets along here
had previously a cost of four.
But now it says
that it's replaced
with the cost of infinity.
So it will replace--
this routing table
entry would go away.
And it would replace it with no
route and a cost of infinity.
And that's what would propagate.
Now, these advertisements
are done periodically.
So what D is doing,
of course, is
to send out two advertisements,
one this way and one that way.
Now, this thing is
not going to reach,
because this link
no longer is alive.
But this advertisement works.
So when A receives the next
distance vector advertisement
from D, it now knows that
it has a cost-- you know,
that link is actually alive
and it has a route going there.
Now, this particular
example is a little tricky,
because what's happening here,
of course, is that A previously
had two ways of getting to D--
4 plus 3 this way,
or 7 that way.
If it were previously
using that,
then A would also have no
route to the destination.
And then it would have
to wait for this guy
to send that route.
So when it sent that route, A
would now have a valid route
to the destination.
And in A's next advertisement,
it would send that route over
to these two guys.
So it would send out saying
that D is at cost seven.
And it would do the
same thing here.
The D is at cost 7
to C. Now, C, when
it receives the
next advertisement
that D is at cost 7,
compares that route
against its current route, which
is now infinity, and replaces
in its routing table
entry D infinity with D,
this link here, and a cost
of 4 plus 7, which is 11.
So it would replace it with
D. Let me call this L1, L1,
and a cost of 11.
And then on its
next advertisement,
C would send that out to B
according to that advertisement
schedule.
And similarly here, S, when
it receives this from A
would, on its next
advertisement,
after integrating the
route to destination D,
which would have a
cost of 1 plus 7, 8,
it would send out an
advertisement this way,
which would have a cost of 8.
And B, when it receives
both of these things,
would compare a cost of 8 on
this link against a cost of 1
plus 4 plus 7, which is 12.
And it would find that
8 is smaller than 12.
And therefore, B
would use this way
of getting to the destination.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
receiving hello packets
from all its neighbors.
And it's just, if a link is
alive and a hello shows up,
it processes it.
And the moment the
first hello shows up,
it declares the link
to be alive again.
Finding that someone is
alive is a lot easier
than finding that they're
dead, at least if they're
in networks.
It's probably true in life, too.
But it's certainly
true of networks
because all you have to know--
I mean, assuming there's no
malicious nodes, detecting
that a node is alive,
it takes one packet.
Detecting that a node is
dead, you're not sure.
Maybe the link was down.
Maybe it was just
a transit failure.
Maybe a packet was lost.
So it's a lot harder to find
that something has crashed
than it is to find that
something's working.
But yeah, so you keep
listening for hello packets.
OK, so this is how it converges.
Now eventually, of
course, because there's
some correct working
path, eventually it
will all converge to
the correct answer.
If later at some point and
then this link comes back up,
the same thing occurs,
because all of this stuff
is being done periodically.
And so periodically,
these advertisements
are going to be sent.
C is going to find that
there's a better route
to go to D via this link as 0.
It advertises D
now at a cost of 4.
And eventually all of
the nodes figure it out.
And they converge back
to the right answer.
OK.
And you can see that the
link state protocol--
the convergence is actually
a little bit easier
because again, there--
the nodes are periodically
advertising these links.
So what's going to happen
in a link state protocol is
if you take the same picture--
and previously the
nodes all had routes.
And many of those routes
went through that link.
You have to wait for the next
link state advertisement, which
would tell you after this
hello protocol discovers that C
discovers that this
link has failed,
it takes that next link
state protocol advertised--
link state advertisement
by which all
of the nodes through
the flooding process
discover that this
link has failed.
And they all run
Dijkstra's algorithm again.
And they will find the
correct new answer,
which will take
them through paths
that bypass this failed link.
Now, the same logic
applies in both protocols
to when a node fails.
If this node were to
fail, you can sort of
think through-- the
node failing is actually
equivalent to all of the links
coming out of the node failing.
So it's a somewhat
harder problem
in terms of just making sure
that you're able to find
the routes correctly.
But this node failing is
really the same as all
of the links attached
to that node failing.
And in a link state
protocol, it'll
eventually-- you'll
discover that.
And all of the nodes will
compute routes this way.
And similarly in a
distance vector protocol
that's what happens.
Now, so far in
this picture, I've
assumed that once you have these
failures and then you pause,
nothing else happens.
There's no more failures,
no packets that are lost,
and so on.
But life's actually not so kind.
What will happen in practice
is that, first of all,
before I get to why this stuff
is a lot more complicated,
does everyone understand
how these things work
and how they converge
correctly to the right answer
after failure and after
recovery from failure?
Any questions?
OK.
So now let me tell
you all the ways
in which this story goes wrong.
The first way the
story goes wrong is--
let me do it in the
context of a link state
protocol with a very,
very simple picture.
Let's say you have--
I think I have a slide.
All right.
Let's say you have the picture
that I've shown up there,
so very, very simple picture.
There's A, B, and D.
D is the destination.
And this is some path.
So let's say that what
happens is that normally when
there's no failures, the way
to go from B to D is via A.
So B, A, D. And A
goes to D directly.
Now, let's assume
that this link fails.
If that link fails
and things work great,
what's going to happen is
that in the next link state
advertisement, A tells B
that AD no longer exists.
A knows the correct
link state from B.
And so it computes its path
via B, its route via B.
And similarly, B realizes
that AD doesn't exist anymore.
And it computes an
alternate route that way.
But let's say what
happens is that AD fails.
And then in the next link state
advertisement that A sends out,
that packet is lost.
Let's say that A's link
state advertisement to B
is just lost.
Packets could get lost.
Now we have a problem because
A knows that this has failed.
And therefore, when it computes
its Dijkstra's algorithm
or shortest path algorithm,
it knows that what it wants
is a route going like that.
But B, on the
other hand, doesn't
know that link AD has
failed, because it
didn't see that link state
advisement which was lost.
So what B does is compute
its routing table entry,
which is the same as
it was before, going
through that link over here.
Now you have a
problem because when
A gets a packet
that it now-- a data
packet that it wants to send
to destination D, previously
it sent it this way.
But now it knows
that link has failed.
So it sends the packet to
B, because its route for D
is via B. Well, B
gets that packet
and looks it up in
its routing table.
And B believes that the
way to get to D is via A.
So it sends it back to A.
Well, A gets that packet
and says, oh, that's great.
This is a packet for
destination D. I look it up
in my routing table.
It goes via B. And
this thing [INAUDIBLE]
for pretty much as
long as you want.
This thing here is the simplest
example of a general phenomenon
called a routing loop.
So the first thing
that can happen when--
during the process
of route convergence,
various kinds of pathologies
and problematic conditions
could happen.
And one of them
is a routing loop.
The second thing
that could happen--
and I showed you that here--
where during the
process of convergence,
C does not have a
route to this link--
to the destination
D. But B thought
it had a route going via
C. But in fact, C just
dropped that packet.
That's the second
condition that happens.
It's a dead end.
So both of these things can
happen during the process
of convergence.
Now, these routing
loops are particularly
problematic because when
you have a routing loop,
this is an example of
a two-hop routing loop.
A goes to B. B goes to A goes
to B. So it bounces twice.
But you can have more
complicated routing loops.
You could have a routing
loop with four hops that
looks like-- or four
nodes involved, as opposed
to two nodes, where
this is destination D.
And this A thinks that
you have to go that way.
B thinks that you
have to go this way.
C thinks you have
to go this way.
And let's call this guy E. He
thinks you have to go that way.
And this could happen.
So you end up with
packets cycling around.
Now, these packets
cycling around--
you know, there's
really no way to--
once you have routing table
entries that have somehow
converged, until it gets
fixed, somehow if they've
converged to routes that--
where for B, you have
to use this link,
and C has to use this
link, and so forth,
and you get a cycle,
what ends up happening
is these packets cycle forever.
There's really no way to avoid
the packets cycling forever.
Now, this is, of course--
eventually this will be fixed.
If the routing protocol
eventually converges,
it will eventually
discover that this is wrong
and find the correct answer.
But during the process
of convergence,
bad things could
happen like this.
And that's why we have on
packets in packet switch
networks a field called
the hop limit field.
And that's on a data packet.
So you have the source
of the packet sets
a hop limit-- let's say 32.
It just says that I need
to get to the destination
and I know it shouldn't
take more than 32
hops, no matter what happens.
And then every node that-- every
switch that gets this packet
reduces the hop limit by 1.
And eventually when the
hop limit gets to zero,
the packet's discarded.
So this is a way to flush
packets out of the network.
And usually you use this
mechanism to handle the case
when you get stuck
in a routing loop,
you don't want these packets
to cycle around forever
and ever and ever, because these
packets move around the network
in milliseconds.
And the routing
protocols take minutes
to converge, or many,
many seconds to converge.
So that's many,
many milliseconds.
These packets could remain
in the network forever
and ever using the bandwidth
and no one's getting any use out
of it.
So you have this hop limit
field to flush packets out
of the system.
But of course, what
we'd like to do
is to design protocols with
guaranteed no routing loops
at all.
Unfortunately, it's
impossible to do that.
But what we can try to do
is to reduce and mitigate
the effects of routing loops.
Now, I want to go through a few
more examples of routing loops
in--
this is in the link
state protocol.
I want to actually
now talk about what
happens with a distance
vector protocol
and show you why this basic,
simple distance vector
protocol, which is the
first routing protocol that
was invented, has some problems
and how we go about fixing it.
And eventually I'll talk
about how this is all
used on the internet today.
So here's how a
distance protocol--
a distance vector
protocol might get
stuck in a weird
kind of routing loop.
So let's take this example
here where you have five nodes
and we're all interested in
finding routes to destination
E. And the general lesson
I want to get at here
is that a distance vector
protocol is extremely simple,
but it only works
on small networks.
And for bigger networks,
we want something better.
So that's where
the story's going.
So let me refresh where we
are, all the discussion I
had so far.
So let's assume that link
AC fails in this picture.
So what you would like to--
and assume that all link costs
are 1.
So we don't worry about
costs at this point.
What you want to have happen is
for A to discover that this--
A discovers that's failed.
And when the routing
converges, you
would like A to use this link
as its route to destination E.
And the cost would be 1,
1, 1, which would be 3.
All right.
So when A discovers failure,
it sends a cost of E
is infinity to its neighbor--
in particular, to B.
And then B, of
course, has a route
to destination E at cost 2.
B advertises that to
A. And then A says, now
I have a route to
destination E. And thus, this
is an example of a good
converging routing protocol.
Everything's good.
Now, let's assume I
complicate the picture.
Let's assume that
link BD also fails.
So now what's the
correct answer?
Well, these two guys
have a route to E.
But the network has
become disconnected.
So the correct answer, the
correct convergent answer
here is that A and B both
discover and instantiate
in the routing
tables entries that
say that E is at
a cost of infinity
because there's no
path, which means
that it's an infinite cost.
So when a packet arrives
at B for destination DE,
you just drop the packet.
But this could happen.
So here's an example
of how that happens.
So let's say that
this link fails.
B discovers that through
the hello protocol.
And at this point, B changes
its routing table entry
so that E is at infinity.
B had previously sent
information to A saying
that B was--
E was at distance 2 or cost 2.
And now it says,
well, I told you
that E was at cost 2 before.
But I'm changing my mind.
It's at cost infinity.
And A says, OK.
My entry for E now has cost
infinity and both of them
have converged correctly
to the right answer.
Now, unfortunately,
that's not the only thing
that could happen.
This was in the lucky situation
when B discovered it had failed
and immediately sent
out its cost to A.
But what could happen
is a little different.
What could happen
is that B could
discover that D has failed
and change its routing table
entry to infinity.
But before it gets a chance
to send out its advertisement
to A--
or perhaps it sends
out its advertisement
with a cost of infinity
to A, but it got lost--
in either of those
cases, what could happen
is A could send out
its routing table
cost to B for destination
E, because that's what's
happening periodically, right?
Every node is
periodically running this.
And the times are
all asynchronous.
Every node has its own notion
of when it should send out
its advertisement.
So what happens now is A sends
out an advertisement to B
saying it has a route to
destination E at a cost of 3,
which is very valid, right?
After all, A does have a
route in its routing table
to E, whose cost is 3.
It so happens it goes
through B. But A doesn't yet
know that that
link BD has failed.
Now we're a little
bit in trouble
because B now believes that
its routing table entry for E
is at cost of infinity because
BD has failed that link.
And now it sees an advertisement
from A with a better cost.
The route says,
wow, this is cool.
I now have a path
of cost 3 via A
to E, which is better
than my cost of infinity.
And so I'm going to assume
that I have an entry
to E at a cost of 4.
So now you can see
that this is actually
not a valid route at all.
Now, B actually,
on the face of it,
has no way of knowing if A is
telling it a different route.
So it could
conceivably be the case
that A has a different route
going that way whose cost is 3.
And A can legitimately
have a cost of 3 to E
that it could be
telling B about.
But in this protocol,
there's no way for B
to distinguish that case
from the case where A is just
repeating to B a route
that it received via B.
But it's just telling it
that it has a route via B.
Now, B, therefore, says that
it has a cost of 4 to E.
And it sends that to
A. And A says, whoa.
Previously, the cost was 3--
2 from B. And now
B is telling me
that the cost is
4, which means I
need to make my cost equal
to 4 plus 1, which is 5.
And I'm going to
send that back down.
B says, all right.
I've got a cost of 5.
Previously, that same
thing had a cost of 3.
So now I'm going
to make my cost 6.
And this goes on forever.
Now, in the meantime, if
there are packets showing up
at either A or B
for destination E,
they're just going to go
bouncing between these two
guys.
This is a routing loop.
Now, when does this stop?
When do these guys stop sending
these incrementing costs?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You need a value of infinity.
You need to say
that, at some point,
they're going to reach infinity
and we're going to stop.
So in other words,
for this protocol
as it's presented to converge
in a legitimate amount--
reasonable amount of time,
your value of infinity
should be small.
So this thing has
a colorful name.
It's called counting
to infinity.
Now, in reality, in any network,
the cost of infinity cannot be
smaller than the minimum--
the maximum minimum cost path.
If you have a minimum cost
path that has a cost of 75,
for whatever reason, infinity
had better be bigger than 75.
Right?
So what it means
is that you have
a problem with this protocol.
It works great on
small networks.
But it only works
on small networks.
And the reason for that is that
it needs the value of infinity
that's not very big.
So this is why distance
vector protocols are only
used for really
simple, small networks.
And the moment the network
becomes a certain size
or when you want costs
that are large values,
you really can't
use this protocol.
So how do you fix this problem?
Any ideas on how to
solve this problem?
Clearly the internet
is pretty big.
We're not counting to infinity
throughout the whole internet.
Or at least, we
don't think we are.
So how would you
fix this problem?
Any ideas?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we do have
a hop limit on packets.
So all these packets
might have a hop limit.
So the packets don't remain in
the network for a long time.
But that doesn't solve the
problem of the routing protocol
to converge takes a time
which is this counting
to infinity problem.
So you want a better
solution in some way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's one good
idea, which is--
in fact, that's how
they started trying
to solve this problem,
which is, if you have
a route to a destination
coming from a neighbor,
don't send back the
same route to them.
In other words, in this
case, A's route to E
was via B. So A should not
advertise a route to E--
a route for destination
E back to B.
If you do that,
there's a name for it.
It's called split
horizon and the notes
describe how this
protocol works.
Or you could do even better.
A could advertise to B that
its route to destination E
has a cost of infinity,
forcing B to definitely
not use that route,
no matter what
happens, because A
perceived that route via B.
So A should tell B that
the cost of that route
is infinity because under
no circumstances does A
want B to use the same
route that it received.
So you could do that.
The trouble with that is it
doesn't-- it solves these
two-hop loop problems, but it
doesn't solve four-hop loop
problems.
So you could have a situation
where this link fails and C
discovers that.
But before C sends
out its update,
B sends out its route to C.
And so C thinks it can use B.
In the meantime, B thinks
it has a route via A.
So you might end up with
packets cycling around
in longer hop loops.
So that idea that you
had doesn't actually
solve the more general problem.
So any other
modification or idea
that can solve the problem?
So one thing you
could do is something
called path vector, which
is what you could do
is every node, rather than
just sending the cost,
it could send the entire
route, that is-- sorry.
It could send the entire path.
It could send the
list of nodes that
corresponds to that particular
route in its routing table
advertisement.
So I'll show that
with a picture here.
So E could send out not
just its destination
and a cost, which previously, it
would say that to come to E, E
would say the cost is zero.
But it could now say the cost
is zero and the path is E.
And then each of these
other guys, C and D,
could send out their
own advertisements
saying the cost is 2 or
whatever-- the cost is 1.
But they could also say
that the path is the DE.
So D says that my path to get
to E is DE in its advertisement.
And B here, when
it receives that,
could send out its
own path vector,
which is the list of nodes
or the list of switches
that corresponds to an actual
path that's advertised.
And now the rule for
how you integrate
a route into your routing
table entries is very simple.
If you see an advertisement
with your own identity
in that advertisement,
then you know
that that's just a
rumor that you started
or you were involved with, so
you shouldn't integrate it.
So in particular, in
this example here,
if B, for example, were to
see an advertisement from A
with a path that was A, B, D, E,
then B wouldn't integrate that.
So what would happen in the
picture I showed you before
is if these two links were
to fail, what would happen
is that B would have--
if that link failed,
B would have sent
that BDE over here.
And when A advertises
that back to B,
it would have ABDE show up.
And B now sees ABDE.
And B finds that its own
name is in that vector
or in that
advertisement and says,
I should pay no
attention to that.
And as long as you find
your own name somewhere
in that list of nodes
that routing advertisement
went through, you know that
you shouldn't pay any attention
to it because you were involved
in creating that advertisement.
And so you shouldn't
pay attention to it.
This protocol is
called path vector.
It's used on the
internet in something
called the Border
Gateway Protocol,
which runs between
autonomous systems.
And that's actually what
makes the internet essentially
converge and not have
these routing loops that
go between different
internet service providers.
Any questions, comments so
far about any of this stuff?
So let me summarize everything
about routing protocols.
And we pick this up in
recitation with some problems
tomorrow.
So the last two lectures
in recitation, we've
spoken about the network layer.
And the main problem that's
solved by the network layer
is how to get packet
routing to work.
How do you find good paths
between different nodes
in the network, between
different switches
in the network?
Now, we've separated
out the tasks
of routing from forwarding.
Forwarding is what happens when
a packet arrives at a switch.
There's a lookup that
happens in a routing table.
You take the destination.
You look it up in
the table, find
the link in the routing
table, and ship the packet.
So that's done--
usually you want
it to be done very, very fast.
Routing is the process
by which the nodes
create routing table entries.
And that's a very
distributed process.
It runs amongst all
of the other-- all
of the switches in the network.
We looked at two routing
protocols-- link state
and distance vector.
In distance vector,
the computation
is distributed with these
Bellman-Ford update steps.
And the distance
vector protocol is
very beautiful in that
it's very, very simple.
It works for small networks.
But to make the ideal
work for bigger networks,
you have to enhance the
distance with the actual path.
And if you enhance
it with the path,
you actually avoid a lot
of these routing loops
that show up.
You can't eliminate it.
But you can mitigate
the effect of it.
In the link state
protocol, there's
actually more work that's done.
There's a lot more information
that's flooded between nodes.
But the protocol
converges quicker
than these distance vector and
path vector protocols usually.
Link state protocol, you flood
this neighbor information.
You consume more bandwidth.
There's a lot more bandwidth
that's used in the network
in flooding it.
And the computation
is centralized.
You run Dijkstra's
shortest path.
So what the internet
does in general--
I'll pick up on this two
lecture-- or three lectures
from now, when I talk about
how the internet really
works and applies the
concepts we've studied.
What you'll find is that
networks like MIT's network
will run a protocol like--
a link state like protocol
to achieve connectivity
between nodes inside MIT.
And then routers at the
edge of MIT connecting
to other internet
service providers
run a path vector
protocol, like BGP.
And all of these
things work together
and they work because
ultimately, all of the switches
create these routing
table entries
that have a mapping between
destinations and routes
or links that have to be used.
So that's the routing story.
We'll pick it up in
recitation tomorrow
and see you back on Wednesday.